we call this synergy there may be an
iron-rich and Eisen but I'm a team
player and I love this show mr. Mercedes
that's on audience Channel tonight at
8:00 Eastern Time and ATT original
series based on Stephen King's warped
mind and David Kelly and Jack bender
bringing it to the small screen and in
this outstanding show is someone who's
outstanding in it sitting right next to
me Kelly Lynch good to see you Congrats
on this show thank you you know I don't
how it was difficult for me to get to
sleep after seeing the first episode
what is it like acting and you you play
the mom of mr. Mercedes himself and you
have some issues hookups there she's
agoraphobic and alcoholic and she has a
very strange somewhat incestuous
relationship with her son but you drop a
song oh I just sort of like sort of that
yeah and there's that and there's really
glad I don't have a boy just saying I
helped a little bit that much yes and
the amazing Harry Treadway just we we
just went for it you know I'm there are
these people in the world and her
boundaries are really sort of nebulous
and she's not quite sure who she is or
what she is to him she's a mother
sometimes and she loves him very dearly
and he was one of those kids was a
little bit off and she feels like she's
just trying to fill that space in some
way for him he doesn't have many friends
but she's you know basically sitting
with the tumbler of vodka and a reality
TV show going
you know Danite so she's not really that
focused in a way so what was it like
meeting Stephen King as he is warped in
person when you you chat with him it was
amazing that has to be it was amazing
I'm a huge Stephen King fan you know I'm
a huge fan so it was I just felt like
just doing like the list of all that you
know and watch him go like whatever you
know bye Gary you know but yeah he's
extremely tall so as a tall person
myself I felt very demure which was
great
I liked uh um even that's not Stephen
King doesn't usually make people feel
that way he doesn't usually I felt a
very very very feminine yeah and I
almost I almost like ran into them
oh my god Stephen King I'm dead
Hartsville then he's like I know I know
I you sad boy them yeah that I know and
I'm like how are we do is it is it good
do you like it he goes I've seen the
first four episodes they're amazing I
wouldn't be here unless I loved it and
they needed a cameo that day that we all
watched you did a little cami on the
show which is I have not seen that you
know it's coming up okay and it's super
funny and really plays like a school
principal or or or somebody who has no
moral problems whatsoever well he has
problems you'll see what it is Friday
you'll see he has major problems in news
little cameo yeah The Shining for me
really that's that's it I mean shining
and obviously you know it as well I mean
anything yeah I mean I read it I read it
all yeah and the stand that's great and
now mister Mercedes right here on on on
audience so you are from covalent you
are from Minnesota correct I'm minutes
away okay so yeah did you ever have that
oh yeah when I first moved to New York
people was like saying say quote quote
like for you and my mother after
watching Fargo she called me up and she
said Cal adage is he Fargo she said yeah
what do you think did you think it was
funny like the wood chipper Delia did
you like that and I said well I thought
it was pretty funny okay well I I guess
I just didn't get it but people back
home don't act like and then did you
grow up a Vikings fan there usually yeah
involved big Vikings fan I'm not if I
can't say it on the show York I'd rather
play football than watch football until
the end of seasons I don't know I don't
know what position are you you you throw
a Gidget I just like to toss a football
with the husband one in the backyard
kind of thing and drive our dog nuts but
I like waiting til in all sports that
aren't because I'm a jock and I like to
play things you know so I like watching
when the heat is really on towards the
end of seasons and I'm kind of keep up
to every so you know with what's going
on and then I tune in towards the end
but I grew up with the friend talking
and Vikings
coming to my family's restaurant hold on
a second okay let's let's stop there
yeah so you have your family on the
restaurant family on a restaurant called
the boulevard cafe okay man I was hoping
was called Roadhouse
what can I know right that's another no
that's you put a pin in that you should
just hang on right um and yeah and they
would they would just come and it was
one of those places well now every place
in America seems like you can get like a
plate of food like this but it was one
of those places and you could get you
know big steak and a big baked potato
and nice egg salad and all the stuff and
it was a really cool you know place and
all the North Stars were always there
the Vikings were there were stars I TAS
down that's that's great so but Fran
Tarkenton would just walk through the
door and you yeah and I'm every family
establishment yeah I remember thinking
you know he's he's I said to my mom once
she's like he's not so tall I know you
know he's not such a huge inch she goes
yeah but look what he does right my mom
is a there you know just the huge
football fan as well so that was kind of
cool right but and I guess that's why it
wasn't technically a purple people eater
like the other guys were big enough to
come in and actually get your
establishment finished up yeah
so that was that's pretty neat grew up
around the Vikings and the North Stars
and having it right there Kelly Lynch
here on the Rich Eisen show okay let's
get into some of your your history how
did you get involved with Drugstore
Cowboy I love that movie a great movie
it really is it's still resonant today
yeah you know it really was it really is
it's especially now with you know the
amount of pharmaceutical drug addiction
where they were living with you know and
it's just it's a it's an epidemic and
it's a sad nightmare well I saw that the
spine of Drugstore Cowboy at my agents
office and I was like wow that looks
what is that that's a great title and
she said oh come on they want like Patti
Smith it's a druggie thing and you know
they want Patti Smith and Bob Dylan to
do this and I thought well that's going
to happen you know that was the original
that was the original idea that those
two people did okay okay and down to me
and Matt Dillon and you know but I read
it and fell in love with the script it
was so beautifully written and then I
watched a 20 minute short that Gus Van
Zandt had done was the only thing he had
directed before and I thought I will do
anything to get in this movie anything
and so they were you know worried about
I was pretty you know
girl and I stayed up the night before my
meeting with with Gus and looked so bad
that he he was like kind of after my
audition he said that was really good
but are you okay like I was just so I
mean that my harem of the bags into my
eyes it was it was kind of like what
isn't that part of part and part yeah
part of did you walk in your airbrush
Christ or a cowboy yeah right yeah I
hadn't gotten any sleep the night before
I met him so I was I think I was a
little raw perhaps but um but yeah I got
the part in the room and Gus said okay
so you're going to you know be Diane and
remember that the producers were like
well gosh you haven't met anybody else
and there's a lot of people we should
meet and she was great but he said no I
want her you know and that was such an
amazing thing as a young actor to have
was in my second movie or something to
have and in the rule really the first
movie where people could see that I
could act which is important I mean I
think in cocktail people could see I
looked all right in a bikini but I don't
you the acting was really front and
center no but I mean in Roadhouse do you
could see that I could you know like
pick I'm a staple some right right I
could staple and and how pain doesn't
hurt doesn't hurt except when I staple
people I want to say that it probably
did hurt exactly so so Roadhouse came
before Drugstore Cowboy or came right
before dragster cobweb literally I rap
draw it has right into Drugstore Cowboy
it was like such a funny for those in
the movie theater at the same time he
much yeah so one minute you're in Gus
Van Zandt another one two completely
different fans although ideally ironic
Roadhouse yeah people who love Roadhouse
for the you know for the fun of it are
also Drugstore Cowboy fans but they're
usually different groups people right I
like the crossover fans the best how
what was it like on the set of Roadhouse
it was fantastic I mean it was one of
the best times I've ever had
first of all I mean Sam Elliott and
Patrick Swayze oh my god nothing like
the Patrick Swayze use the nicest guy on
earth like this we just nicest guy
everybody loved him he was super funny
and you know how many guys are
ballerinas and quarterbacks you know
played football you know he was mr.
dirty dancing already
yeah oh yeah septums he was and you know
just a really great athlete and and you
know he kind of inspired me when I did
Charlie's Angels he did all of his own
stunts and Cameron Diaz and I did all of
our stunts except for one drop from a
bell tower that they wouldn't let us do
but we were like determined to do
everything and I watched Patrick work so
carefully on his all of his stunts and
everything and it was it made it fun
that part of the fun of the movie is
knowing that that's Patrick fighting is
you know Marshall Teague as well as
opposed to two stunt guys sure Kelly
Lynch here on the Rich Eisen show and so
it's on Roadhouse is on Carly right now
it is not wearing like my arrest right
where in the world Roadhouse is plane at
yes everywhere somewhere is it true the
Murray brothers call your husband every
time it's on or they see it every time
it's on is that a true story that isn't
you sorry can you explain this the
genesis of this story um how often it's
well it started with Bill Murray I think
bill had never really seen Roadhouse all
the way through and watched it one day
years and years ago and came to the love
scene and basically what it was it upset
him was that I was getting thrown again
so it looks like a very painful rock
wall and he thought it was hilarious
exactly that kind of profanity I did
have quite a bit of padding behind me I
just want her to tell that to the fans
yeah I did no blood was shed but yeah I
am kind of hitting that wall and it does
look painful so he thought you should
call my husband up and he disguised his
voice which never works as you can tell
it's Bill Murray he was like magic hey
magic so he's doing something with your
wife and a rocking wall is there my wife
Judy she was like you know so was we
thought it was like a one-off it was
pretty funny and then it came to a time
where we he was like in Russia and so
the time difference was a little
upsetting in LA he calls my husband to
say again and then all of a sudden his
brothers started calling and Ryan Doyle
bong yeah there's a but thirty thousand
Murray but I was watching and there's a
none so far she hasn't gotten involved I
don't know she has a TV Bill Murray
sitting in Russia
turn television on in there I am
Roadhouse's on it he's still keeping yes
tradition going yeah he is he's doing it
and I in fact I'm watching Anthony
Bourdain who I love watching his show
and
Charleston and Bill Murray's on the show
and they talk about it I'm saying it's
like my gosh well eating like frogs legs
or something like that yeah look good
whatever they're eating but damn you
then now here comes mr. Mercedes which
is great again i congrats on that thank
you know we're so pleased i mean you
read you know you read a script and you
you get together and you shoot something
and eat it just felt like everything I
thought this could be it wasn't better
because I'm you know my storyline is
with one group of you know a small group
of people I'm I'm just kind of a
sheltered screwed-up woman but but
seeing every all you know all the
characters and everything I've seen
quite a few of the episodes now I'm just
so proud of it and that the reviews have
been amazing and people are
understanding what we're trying to what
we're trying to say which is you know
it's about the monsters within us it's
not this use giving Kings supernatural
Stephen King he wanted to he wanted to
do this kind of hard-boiled detective
show and had an idea about how to bring
a detective back into the world who's
retired
um and it's brendan gleeson who's normal
I mean just working with him every time
I get on suckas you know I'm Kelly Lynch
I'm Irish
I like dropping to Molly Shannon the
Irish you know it's just yeah brendan
gleeson he's just you know he's an
international treasurer he is that he is
that what your actual kids think of this
mother you're portraying how many kids
do I have one well she's you know she's
a she's an actor as well she was just on
Twin Peaks but she she be an animator
she works at DreamWorks and the
rebooting Shira which is very cool kind
of empowered young princess of power but
she she knows how much I like
complicated multi-layered characters and
the fact that this is an incestuous
mother just makes her crack-up you know
is what's good you know it's a tricky
one but yeah I love being thrown I mean
I was I played a dude on the l word you
know I played a transgendered character
on the l word
opposite Pam Grier goddess Pam Grier
rush that was a toughest job I've ever
had as far as I was like so worried they
were going to make me look like Clint
Howard and I wouldn't be handcuffed that
fast I mean really when it isn't
everything isn't everything and you know
there for good look for comedy but not
you're kinda manly Pam Grier ya know
right I know that Quinn Howard look I
mean anybody's Ron disease Ron's brother
and not everything I see everything
gonna run boys Ron's brother what is
what is your before before I let you go
what is your remote drop movie when
you're because Roadhouse is that for so
many people
yeah that it come across doesn't matter
where they are just Robin what is what
is your mouse key or Caddyshack they're
kind of a tactic by the way Ben Gazzara
who was the bad guy in road house with
that in in the big lebowski exactly he
just passed away too you know he was
amazing so The Big Lebowski which is
stupid Chisholm that's a long one too
it's another Coen Brothers movie love it
I love the Coen Brothers or Caddyshack
Minnesota come brothers Minnesota see
this never says what you should do is
that you should call you should have
your husband call Bill Murray
every time Caddyshack is on that's a
good idea if you like a really good idea
yes come on oh he exactly like you have
his own method you've never thought of
that
no did I just give you a great idea yes
I am one of the only people that has a
real phone number to Bill Murray
everyone else has an 800 number oh yeah
you have that real number the real
number okay not that he answers the
phone let's call her it's not to say
well Tom right now he doesn't he doesn't
even yet he'll answer a text
occasionally but okay but if i text
certain things like maybe about a cute
girl then all of a sudden there might be
in a quicker response okay yeah so you
know you know how to press the buttons
I'm just saying next time the Caddy
shacks on your husband should just rank
you for that you are wanker
thank you for coming on early lunch at
Kelly Lynch on Twitter to follow Kelly
Lynch and absolutely have to follow mr.
Mercedes which is on audience tonight at
8:00 Eastern Time a clip for the
television audience when we come back
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to